Russland im Krieg wenn man es nicht
wüsste könnte man es auf den Straßen von
St Petersburg und nicht nur hier leicht
vergessen
[Musik]
[Applaus]
das Leben genießen während im
Nachbarland Leben ausgelöscht werden das
vergangene Jahr hat auch in Russland
viel verändert und gleichzeitig
scheinbar nichts zerstörte
Lebensentwürfe tote an der Front doch
die Menschen wirken auf mich oft seltsam
unbeteiligt
keine Rufe nach Frieden oder Freiheit
das Schweigen der Russen und Russen ist
es Zustimmung Angst oder haben sie sich
damit abgefunden machtlos zu sein ich
besuche menschen die den Mut aufbringen
mit uns zu sprechen obwohl der Staat Sie
daran hindern will und Menschen die uns
gegenüber sonst schweigen weil sie
westlichen Fernsehteams eigentlich
Misstrauen
[Musik]
St Petersburg die alte Zarenstadt hat
einen neuen selfie-spot im Stadtzentrum
Leuchten seit kurzem zwei Herzen St
Petersburg umarmt das ukrainische Mario
Pool
das sind unsere neuen Territorien wir
sind Partnerstädte unsere Stadt hilft
mariopol beim Wiederaufbau
wer Mario Puls zerstört hat hören wir
sie nicht erklären wir sind hier
verabredet mit einem der wenigen Männer
die sich noch trauen Putins Regime offen
zu widersprechen Alexander buttberg
bezirksabgeordneter und Jurist etwas
abseits des Denkmals und der Polizisten
in Zivil erklärt Alexander wie heikles
geworden ist Kritik zu äußern
Menschen befinden sich in Haft wegen
ihrer Worte weil sie ihren Gedanken
gegen den Krieg Ausdruck verliehen haben
das hat nicht die Dimensionen wie in der
Stalinzeit
das ist ein selektiver
kennengelernt haben wir Alexander
letzten September
[Musik]
Putin ließ in Moskau die Annexion von
vier ukrainischen Gebieten feiern
[Applaus]
patriotische Hochstimmung angeleiteter
Jubel für Alexander Ausdruck dunkelster
Entwicklungen
es ist der wahrscheinlich dramatischste
Moment seit 91 in Russland wurde ein
faschistisches Regime gebildet
der Lokalpolitiker will das nicht
widerstandslos hinnehmen immer wieder
schickt er uns in den kommenden Monaten
Videos wie dieses ich werde dich
gefangen nehmen und dir beibringen die
Heimat zu lieben hast du Begriffen sagen
sie erst einmal was sie konkret sagen
wollen ich werde dich gefangen nehmen
ich werde dich festhalten und ihr
beibringen die Heimat zu lieben gut
sprechen Sie was wollen sie sagen
Alexander filmt mit seinem Handy einen
Streit mit Polizisten sie werfen ihm vor
ein kriegssymbol aus der U-Bahn entfernt
zu haben
wir warten auf die Kollegen und
verschaffen uns Klarheit okay sie
sollten lernen ihrer Heimat zu lieben
was für eine Heimat
nicht den Arsch der mächtigen sondern
die Heimat muss man lieben verstanden
sollte es zu brenzlig für ihn werden
will Alexander das Land verlassen aber
bis dahin bleibt er unbequem
ich diskutiere auch mit kultivierten und
gebildeten Leuten die diesen Faschismus
erlegen sind
sie sagen wir müssen für unser Vaterland
einstehen selbst wenn wir sehen dass das
Regime schlecht oder verdorben ist
sie sagen wir müssen trotzdem für die
Heimat das Land und den Staat eintreten
für mich sind Land und Staat aber nicht
das Hauptkriterium wenn es um richtig
oder falsch geht
Heimatliebe Vaterland Patriotismus mit
diesen Schlagworten schwören Politik und
Propaganda das Volk ein den Sinn des
Krieges hinterfragen und patriotisch die
Armee kritisieren strafbar im
vergangenen Jahr habe ich die letzten
Inseln gesellschaftlicher Freiheiten
schwinden sehen im Schatten der
spezialoperation hat Russland
Zensurgesetze erlassen
Menschenrechtsorganisationen verboten
wer anders denkt wer anders liebt als
der Staat des will wird kriminalisiert
deswegen ist Karinas leben gefährlich
geworden mit ihrer Partnerin Betrieb sie
in St Petersburg das Rainbow Café
Treffpunkt für die LGBT-Community und
alle die Lust auf Kuchen hatten
Deutschland die Bahn da wo jetzt die
Getränke stehen da war die Theke
gerade wird ihr ehemaliges Café zu einem
fast food-laden umgebaut
wissen sie dass hier früher ein
lgbt-freundliches Café drin war nein
wusste ich nicht jetzt weiß ich es
er war schon viel unterschiedliches drin
deshalb hat sie wahrscheinlich gebrannt
es gab ein Feuer
der Brand fand statt als Carina das Café
schon aufgegeben hatte doch davor waren
hakenkreuzer an ihren Laden geschmiert
worden irgendwann trauten sich keine
Gäste mehr zu ihnen Carina musste
schließen seit Kriegsbeginn erkennt sie
ihre Stadt kaum wieder
die Menschen haben sich verändert die
Stadt hat sich verändert alles hat sich
verändert
die Leute sind eingeschüchtert
verängstigt verschlossen wortkarg und
brutal geworden
im November hat Russland die Gesetze
gegen die sogenannte lgbt-propaganda
verschärft
aufklärungsmaterialien queere Kunst oder
gleichgeschlechtliches Händchen halten
in der Öffentlichkeit die Gesetze sind
so schwammig formuliert dass für all das
theoretisch Geldstrafen drohen ein
Ablenkungsmanöver der Regierung sagt
Carina
eine Sensation ein Rummel war nötig um
die Blicke vom Krieg abzulenken eure
Söhne eure Kinder tötet man da und
anstatt sich dagegen zu erheben winken
sie froh mit den Händchen und rufen wie
toll es jedoch ist wir haben jetzt keine
LGBT Bewegung mehr ach das ist doch
lächerlich
manchmal habe sie Suizidgedanken erzählt
Carina viele ihrer Freunde haben
begonnen zu trinken um zu vergessen
Angst um den Job Angst vor der Zukunft
Angst davor zu leben wie man ist dass
die Russinnen und Russen sich aus dieser
Lage befreien werden glaubt Carina nicht
seien wir ehrlich die russischen
Menschen sind feige sehr feige sie
werden nichts ändern und wissen Sie
warum
jeder sitzt da und denkt ich habe einen
Kredit ich aber eine Hypothek ich muss
mein Kind in die Schule schicken ich
habe irgendeinen Job und ich bin nicht
bereit dies alles zu verlieren
die wachsende Armut mache die Menschen
immer intoleranter meint Carina zum
Abschied
angeheizt wird die Stimmung Tag für Tag
im russischen Staatsfernsehen homo und
Transsexualität dienen als Beispiele für
die angebliche Verdorbenheit des Westen
gegen dessen Werte und Waffen sich
Russland im Krieg wehnt Julian natürlich
wissen wir nicht wo sie lang geht haben
wir keine Präzisionswaffen
sie verstehen es erst wenn sie
Atombomben den Kopf kriegen das deutsche
Volk wird schon noch sehen welche
naziführer es daran gezogen und an die
Macht gebracht hat
die russisch-deutsche Eiszeit bekommen
auch wir Journalisten zu spüren
bei der Arbeit Rücken uns Aufpasser in
Zivil manchmal ganz schön auf die Pelle
Überwachung
Einschüchterungsversuche seit ca einem
Jahr gehören sie für meine Kollegen und
mich dazu
wer sind diejenigen die putinsystem
unterstützen um das zu verstehen treffe
ich einen echten Patrioten
das wievielte Mal macht man uns zu
Feinden dafür dass unsere Wahrheit eine
Heere ist sinkt Alexander ananicev
diejenigen die uns einst und jetzt zu
Grabe tragen wollen kennen uns nicht und
haben daher Angst heißt es im Text
weiter
bisher ging es in Alexanders Liedern
meist um russische Flüsse oder die Kälte
seit letztem Februar immer öfter um den
Krieg
als ich jung war als ich früher Bücher
gelesen habe schien es mir klar dass wir
nie als erste jemanden angreifen dürfen
niemals wir haben uns stets verteidigt
aber in dieser Situation waren wir
gezwungen als erster anzugreifen
andernfalls hätte man uns zersetzt
man habe ja nicht anders gekonnt das
hören wir in Russland immer wieder er
stehe voll hinter Putins
spezialoperation sagt Alexander seine
Präsidenten ist er dankbar
wir hatten uns damit abgefunden an der
Peripherie zu sein und dann erschien ein
Mann namens Putin
es ist es ist ein Wunder es ist ein
Wunder verstehen Sie dass wir solch eine
Situation haben er hat uns aus dem Sumpf
gezogen
Gedichte und Lieder seien sein Beitrag
zum Kampf sagt er im Juli war er im
Donbass um die russischen Soldaten in
den besetzten Gebieten zu unterstützen
es sind 28 Länder die gegen uns kämpfen
wir sind als ein Land in dem Krieg wer
wird uns helfen vom Prinzip keiner
die NATO Länder kämpfen da doch nicht
was soll das heißen sie kämpfen dort
nicht sie schicken doch Waffen die
deutschen leoparden sind doch schon
unterwegs
ohne ein Gläschen selbstgebrannten und
eine saure Gurke komme ich hier nicht
weg die legendäre russische
Gastfreundschaft durfte ich in meiner
Zeit als Korrespondentin schon oft
erleben doch mit jemandem anzustoßen der
Deutschland als Feind sieht und das
Töten in der Ukraine für unvermeidlich
hält bereitet mir Unbehagen
es mache ihm Freude sich mit Menschen
auszutauschen die anderer Meinung sind
als er und immerhin damit haben wir dann
doch etwas gemeinsam
nein
mit einem Lied über einen Soldaten der
an die Front geht verabschieden
Alexander und seine Tochter mich
[Musik]
für das Vaterland in den Krieg ziehen
das hat den Segen der
russisch-orthodoxen Kirche
was viel mit der engen Beziehung dieser
beiden Männer zu tun haben dürfte
Wladimir Putin und Patriarch Kyrill der
erste
das Kirchenoberhaupt ist einer der
grünsten Unterstützer des Einmarsches in
die Ukraine rückt ihn gar in die Nähe
eines Heiligen Krieges
wenn ein Mensch in der Ausübung des
Militärdienstes stirbt glauben wir dass
dieses Opfer alle Sünden reinwäscht die
dieser Mensch begangen hat
aber sehen das auch die Gläubigen so
einige Autostunden von Moskau entfernt
im sogenannten goldenen Ring sind wir
bei dem Recherchen auf eine etwas andere
Kirche gestoßen
samt außergewöhnlichem Priester
um ihn zu treffen müssen wir an den
Stadtrand von jaroslawil dorthin wo das
russische Dorfleben beginnt
hallo ich heiße
guten Tag sprechen sie Deutsch
ich habe es in der Schule gelernt aber
nur schlecht
in diesem stillgelegten Eisenbahnwaggon
ist Alexej seit einem Jahr Priester
Ikonen in der schaffnerkabine bei Wasser
aus dem Container anfangs sei ja ein
bisschen schockiert gewesen als er
hierher versetzt wurde erzählt Alexey
aber für eine Kirche aus Stein fehlt
gerade das Geld
hat ja das gesagt und so ist der Waggon
zum Ort der Andacht geworden gerade in
den letzten Monaten
in dieser für die Menschen schweren Zeit
da die Ruhe und die Gewissheit
hinsichtlich des morgigen Tages vorbei
sind wenden sich die Menschen Gott zu
emotional ist eine Erschütterung
auszumachen viele Mütter warten jetzt
auf ihre Söhne viele Frauen warten auf
ihre Ehemänner
lange schien für Pater Alexey alles auf
eine Karriere bei der Armee
hinauszulaufen der 31-Jährige stammt aus
seiner militärfamilie seinen Wehrdienst
leistet Alexey bei den Luftlandetruppen
einer von Russlands Eliteeinheiten doch
irgendwie seien die Fragen nach Gut und
Böse immer lauter geworden erzählt er
nach der Grundausbildung ist der daher
vom Militär in den Kirchendienst
gewechselt
ich möchte wissen wie Alex zu seinem
Chef dem Moskauer Patriarchen steht
wenn wir die machtfertikale nehmen so
habe ich als ihr Untergebener keine
Möglichkeit ihren Haltung zu kritisieren
ich kann meine Haltung haben die sich
von ihrer Haltung unterscheiden kann ich
kann sie aber nicht kritisieren
die Macht vertikale das Werkzeug
russischer Eliten um sich die
Gefolgschaft zu sichern im Laufe unseres
Gesprächs wird deutlich dass Alexei
nicht mit allem einverstanden ist
mir scheint dass es ehrlich gewesen wäre
man hätte die Denkmäler jeder Epoche
stehen lassen ein Denkmal für Ivan den
schrecklichen ein Denkmal für Zar
Nikolai ein Denkmal für Lenin für Stalin
ein Denkmal für Putin und für jeden
weiter
stattdessen versucht aber jede Ära alles
dem Erdboden gleich zu machen und aus
den Erinnerungen der Menschen zu
verdrängen deswegen ziehen wir keine
Lehren aus der Geschichte
[Musik]
der Sonntagsgottesdienst ist gut besucht
die Stimmung im Waggon ist feierlich
aber auch bedrückt
in Moskau unterfüttert Patriarch Kyrill
Putins Kurs mit theologisch klingenden
Argumenten verteufelt westliche Werte
fordert Russinnen und Russen auf
Opfer zu bringen in der Provinz scheint
das bei einigen nachzuklingen
[Musik]
Sie unser Nachbar wurde kürzlich
verwundet wir sind alle sehr besorgt wir
beten für ihn wieso ist denn die Front
gegangen
wie hätte er denn nicht gehen können er
ist ein freiwilliger er liebt sein Land
er schützt es wenn niemand es schützt
was wird denn passieren verstehen sie
wir müssen uns verteidigen wir können
uns nicht einfach hinlegen
Ludmilla findet viele viele es an
Hingabe für den Kriegseinsatz
es ist wie wenn man dem Kind das
Spielzeug wegnimmt das Kind weint sofort
los
ähnlich verhalten sich die Jugendlichen
in Bezug auf die Situation
niemand will das Land verteidigen alle
wollen dass sich alles von selbst löst
aber so einfach ist das nicht
einige von Alexis früheren Kameraden
kämpfen heute in der Ukraine andere
Freunde sind vor dem Kriegsdienst
geflohen nach Kasachstan oder Armenien
er könne verschiedene Ansichten in Bezug
auf die spezialoperation verstehen sagt
der Geistliche durch seine Arbeit weiß
er wie viele Tote dieser Krieg fordert
ja ich musste Toten die letzte Messe
lesen es waren recht viele es waren
Militärs das bedeutet eben nicht nur
eine schöne Uniform und irgendwelche
sozialen Garantien sondern auch eine
Gefahr für das Leben
sind auch Freunde von ihnen gefallen
ja nun es sind recht viele Menschen
gestorben
die Gemeinde hat unser Kamerateam offen
aufgenommen was selten ist in diesen
Zeiten statt Misstrauen wird uns Neugier
entgegengebracht
als ich Julias sechs Monate Tochter
bewundere nutzt sie die Gelegenheit
wie steht Deutschland zu dieser
schwierigen Situation mit Russland
die große Frage ist immer wie viel von
dem was gerade passiert ist nur die
Politik und wie viel von den Mensch also
wie viele Menschen stehen auch dahinter
hinter diesem Weg natürlich denken wir
dass das nicht gut ist
sie zeigen uns im Fernsehen alles aber
wir wissen nicht wie es in der Realität
ist das Fernsehen zeigt die eine Sache
aber in Wirklichkeit ist alles anders
sie sagten dass unsere Jungs nicht
sterben und jetzt werden sie tot
zurückgebracht es war nicht nötig ein
Krieg zu beginnen wir müssen diese
Konflikte untereinander lösen
und warum die Politiker das alles
arrangieren ich weiß es nicht
die beiden haben das Gefühl belogen zu
werden und dass die mächtigen die
Zukunft ihrer Tochter aufs Spiel setzen
ohne dass Sie etwas dagegen tun könnten
das Schlimmste auf der Welt ist Krieg
das sind schon viele Menschen in
früheren Kriegen gestorben
und jetzt gibt es noch Atomwaffen ich
weiß nicht was als nächstes passieren
wird
[Musik]
Sieg Stärke Heldentum die Gewissheit im
Zweiten Weltkrieg auf der richtigen
Seite der Geschichte gestanden zu haben
das lässt Zweifel an der heutigen Rolle
ihrer Armee bei vielen Russen gar nicht
erst aufkommen immer wieder beobachte
ich wie die Schablonen von damals über
Akteure von heute gelegt werden dabei
ist Russlands Führung flexibel der Krieg
in der Ukraine wird wahlweise als einer
gegen Nazis oder den Westen dargestellt
80 Jahre ist die Schlacht von Stalingrad
her im heutigen Wolgograd nutzt
Präsident Putin das Gedenken als
tropolisse
wir schicken unsere Panzer nicht an ihre
Grenzen aber wir haben Möglichkeiten zu
antworten
das wird nicht mit dem Einsatz
gepanzerter Fahrzeuge enden
zurück nach St Petersburg
Alexander Budberg will uns einen Ort
zeigen der Tod in Vergessenheit zu
geraten obwohl 400.000
Opfer beider Weltkriege hier am
Stadtrand begraben liegen
Alexander stellt uns Ilja Popo vor seit
20 Jahren kämpft er gegen Baufirmen und
Lokalpolitiker darum dass der alte
Friedhof seine Würde zurückerhält
für uns in St Petersburg den früheren
Linien Grad sind die Erinnerungen an den
Krieg und die Blockade durch die
Wehrmacht heilig
vielleicht liege ich falsch aber ich
glaube das russische Volk befindet sich
jetzt wieder in so einer Situation wie
im Zweiten Weltkrieg
ung über eine Million Menschen starben
während der Leningrader Blockade als die
Wehrmacht die Stadt 29 Monate lang
umzingelte und aushungerte
[Musik]
die Erinnerungen an die Opfer die Helden
und den Sieg der Sowjetarmee über Hitler
Deutschland sind zentral in Russland
darauf baut die Propaganda wenn sie
behauptet heute werde wieder gegen Nazis
gekämpft diesmal in der Ukraine
heute sehen wir reale Erscheinungen von
Narzissmus natürlich erfüllt unser Land
die Bitten jener Menschen die dort
leiden
es geht um zwei vom Geister und von den
historischen Wurzeln her sehr ähnliche
Völker von dem das eine von einem
volksfeindlichen Regime geführt wird und
in einen antirussischen Zustand versetzt
wurden
Alexander will die Männer überzeugen
dass nicht die ukrainische Regierung das
Problem ist sondern die russische
angefangen
wir sollten uns nicht provozieren lassen
gehen vielen Dank
Ilja Popov nimmt seine Mitbürger in
Schutz
wenn Sie diese Fragen stellen bringen
sie die Leute in eine sehr schwierige
Position
das verstehe ich das ist auch etwas was
ich im vergangenen Jahr verändert hat es
ist schwerer geworden offen zu sprechen
sehr schwer zu sprechen
Alexander lässt das nicht gelten die
Russinnen und Russen seien von einem
Virus befallen sagt er und dieser Virus
heiße Propaganda
Zeit für einen Ortswechsel
[Musik]
dorthin wo man noch offen sprechen kann
[Applaus]
tiefless die Hauptstadt im südlichen
Nachbarland georgien ist voll mit
Aufklebern und Graffitis von denen viele
in Russland strafbar wären
[Applaus]
kein Zweifel Georgien steht an der Seite
der Ukraine und ist gleichzeitig zum
Zufluchtsort für zehntausende Russen
geworden
Menschenrechtler Kriegsdienst
Verweigerer Oppositionelle auf der
Flucht vor staatlicher Willkür oder auf
der Suche nach einer Zukunft wir sind
mit Dimitri PAL Yoga verabredet der
Politiker hat St Petersburg mit seiner
Freundin im September verlassen über
Sibirien und Kasachstan ist es
schließlich in Georgien angekommen
das war eine große Erleichterung
wenn ich in Russland meine Wohnung
verlassen habe habe ich immer erstmal
gecheckt ob die Polizei da steht oder so
ob sie mich verhaften wollen und so
weiter es war immer ein Kampf
der Grund für den Druck mit fünf anderen
bezirksabgeordneten hatte die Mitri
einen Appell an die staatsblume
geschickt darin forderten sie das
russische Parlament auf Wladimir Putin
wegen Hochverrats anzuklagen der
Präsident handle nicht im Interesse der
Russischen Föderation seine
spezialoperation schade dem Land
argumentierten die Dimitri und seine
Kollegen
living hier noch
wir haben nicht erwartet dass die
staatsdumma Putin wirklich wegen
hochverratsamt klagen würde
wir verstehen wie das Geschäft läuft
für uns war das eher eine Geste mit der
wir anderen Menschen zeigen wollten dass
sie nicht alleine sind
das ist noch Leute gibt die keine Angst
haben Putin zu widersprechen
Dimitri und seine Freundin Anja meinen
dass viele Menschen in Russland im
Stillen leiden dass sie zum Krieg
schweigen weil sie ja doch nichts daran
ändern könnten
die Menschen haben sich daran gewöhnt
dass alles teurer wird dass die Löhne
niedrig sind dass es wenig Arbeit gibt
aber sie können nicht ertragen dass man
ihre Brüder gaben ihre Söhne einberufen
hat und das mit ihnen etwas
Schreckliches passieren wird dass sie
etwas Schlimmes tun werden und wenn sie
zurückkehren werden sie als andere
zurückkehren
zu diesem Zeitpunkt weiß ich noch nicht
dass Anja gerade auch über ihren eigenen
Bruder spricht dazu später mehr
[Musik]
Dimitri muss los er arbeitet bei einer
russischen IT-Firma die eine
Niederlassung in Georgien gegründet hat
viele von denen die Russland seit
Kriegsbeginn verlassen haben sind jung
und gut ausgebildet Arbeitskräfte die in
der Heimat fehlen
[Musik]
nein deine Karte funktioniert nicht ich
kann Zahlen
ich kann ihnen Rubel zurückgeben wenn
Sie wollen nein nicht wirklich
aber fehlen die Auswanderer auch Putin
oder ist er mit dem Wegzug der jungen
urbanen nicht auch ein Problem los
geworden
das Protestpotenzial in Russland ist
dadurch jedenfalls gesunken mit Dimitri
und Anja bin ich für den Abend wieder
verabredet Zeit tieflist zu erkunden
wer hier essen will muss anerkennen dass
die annektierten Gebiete im Don Bass
Ukrainisch sind und das Putin ein
Kriegsverbrecher ist so steht es auf
diesem Schild
ich will diejenigen kennenlernen die
diesen gesinnungscheck eingeführt haben
und habe Glück Anna und ihre Kollegen
bereiten gerade das Abendgeschäft vor
wir unterstützen die Ukraine wir stehen
in ihrer Seite wir servieren Ihnen
unsere Gerichte umsonst wenn sie hierher
kommen außerdem haben wir Flugblätter
auf den Tischen auf denen erklärt wird
dass Russland der Aggressor ist und auch
20% unseres Landes besetzt sind
wenn die Russen den zustimmen setzen sie
sich und wir behandeln sie wie alle
anderen Gäste auch wenn nicht gehen Sie
viele Georgier sehen sich in einer
Schicksalsgemeinschaft mit der Ukraine
weil Russland 2008 auch ihr Land
angegriffen hat und Moskaus Truppen bis
heute in einigen georgischen Regionen
präsent sind
meine Verwandten Väter meiner Freunde
und so weiter kämpfen jetzt für die
Ukraine viele sind dort hingegangen
ungefähr 15 unserer Leute sind in der
Ukraine schon gestorben im Kampf gegen
Russland
sie machen das aus einer Art Rache
Gefühl
weil sie fühlen was die Ukraine fühlen
sie haben das alles schon mal erlebt
[Musik]
immer mehr georgierinnen und Georgier
fordern eine Visa-Pflicht für Russen
wollen nicht dass die Besatzer sich so
frei in ihrem Land bewegen können
aber spätestens wenn die Leute hören
dass sie Putin kritisch sehen seien Sie
hier willkommen erzählt Anja für die
24-Jährige war der Weg zu ihren
Oppositionellen Ansichten weit
aufgewachsen ist sie in einer
militärfamilie ihr Vater kämpfte im
Afghanistan-Krieg
als wir klein waren wollte ich auch
Soldaten werden die schönen Uniformen
die schicken Schuhe
und wir wohnten in einer Kleinstadt zum
Militär zu gehen ist eine Chance in
einer Großstadt zu ziehen er hat das
dann so gemacht
er das ist Anjas älterer Bruder der als
Soldat in der Ukraine kämpfte bis er
verwundet wurde jetzt ist er zu Hause
bei seiner Frau den zwei Kindern und
kann es nicht abwarten zurück in den
Krieg zu ziehen
er möchte dass ich stolz bin ich kann
aber nicht stolz darauf sein ich kann
mir nur Sorgen machen und ihn bitten zu
bleiben das gefällt ihm nicht
Dimitri mischt sich aus dem Exil weiter
in die russische Politik ein indem er
Appelle an die staatsblume schickt
politisch gesehen befinde sich Putin im
Überlebensmodus meint er und dann
überrascht die Mitri mich als er sagt
dass Putin die Wahlen im nächsten Jahr
Gewinne sei kein Automatismus mehr
es in naher Zukunft denke ich werden wir
etwas sehen was es in Putins Russland
noch nicht gegeben hat
ein Wettkampf zwischen verschiedenen
Teilen des Systems
so der einzige Weg für Putin Wahlen zu
gewinnen ist wenn jeder so tut als habe
er bereits gewonnen
Putins politische Gegner könnten
versuchen Schwächen auszunutzen die der
Kriegsverlauf offenbart in ein Russland
nach Putin würde das Paar zurückkehren
um es wieder aufzubauen wie Anja es
nennt die beiden geben mir Grüße an ihre
Heimatstadt mit
St Petersburg
unter der Oberfläche mögen sich
politische Verhältnisse verschieben
Risse in der Macht auftun diese Männer
scheint das nicht zu erschüttern
[Musik]
Russlands eisfischer
stundenlang harren sie regungslos in der
Kälte aus
geduldig leidensfähig interessiert am
Fisch weniger am großen Ganzen
man fängt was aber bald wird es nichts
mehr zu fangen geben die Fische sind
verschwunden
nicht zu wissen was der nächste Tag
bringt die generelle Mobilmachung
vielleicht oder den offiziellen
Kriegszustand diese Unsicherheit scheint
viele verstummen zu lassen andere werden
in solchen Krisen erst richtig aktiv
Jelena Popova ermutigt die junge
Generation für ihre Rechte einzutreten
die Anwältin hilft Männern die von der
russischen Armee eingezogen werden aber
nicht kämpfen wollen
gerade hat ein Wehrdienstleistender
angerufen und gesagt er ist aus dem
Krankenhaus geflohen man hat ihm gesagt
dass man ihn gesund schreiben und
zurückschicken wird
als im September die Mobilisierung
verkündet wurde habe ihr Telefon nicht
mehr still gestanden erzählt Jelena
das betraf oft Menschen die zum Arbeiten
in die Städte fahren und dort in Hostels
leben wenn danach zu der früh morgens
die Polizei auftauchte und sagte dass
sie jetzt mitkommen müssen ihnen sogar
die Pässe wegnahmen dann war das
gesetzeswidrig sind
auf ihrem Telegramm Kanal erklärt Jelena
den Russen ihre Rechte zum Beispiel das
erstmal nur eine Verwaltungsstrafe droht
wenn man trotz ein Berufungsbescheid
nicht zu Militärdienst erscheint aber
jeder in Russland weiß die Gesetze sind
das eine Repressionen die in der
Realität Folgen können das andere
die Leute sind es nicht gewöhnt dem
Staat Nein zu sagen in die Grenzen
aufzuzeigen ich denke viele waren
überrumpelt sind dem Befehl aus Stress
gefunden
ich denke nur ein kleiner Teil der
Menschen glaubt der Propaganda meinen
sie machen eine gute Sache
befreien jemanden Glauben an das Märchen
das ist dort irgendwelche Nazis gibt
obwohl die Mobilisierung offiziell
beendet wurde werden nach wie vor Männer
zu Armee eingezogen
viele Russinnen und Russen wissen nicht
mehr was sie glauben sollen andere
glauben was am einfachsten erscheint das
schon alles richtig sein wird was von
oben kommt immer wieder bin ich großer
Unsicherheit begegnet in Bezug auf die
eigene Zukunft und das Schicksal des
Landes
eins der mürben der Zustand vielen
scheint da wohl der einzige Ausweg
verdrängen dass sich das eigene Land im
Krieg befindet so gut es eben geht